(pensive music)
- [Narrator] Russian Iskander missiles
like the ones seen in this
Belarusian state media footage,
are capable of launching nuclear warheads.
They've been popping up at
military training grounds
in Belarus as Russia aims to expand
its nuclear capabilities there.
Iskanders are only manufactured in Russia.
They're distinguishable
by the dual set of wheels
on the main chassis, and
this rectangular compartment
from which the missile launches.
Russian President, Vladimir
Putin, has repeatedly boasted
about the transfer of them to Belarus,
ratcheting up the threat of
a nuclear attack from there.
While it's difficult to know
if Russia has transferred
actual nuclear warheads,
we can see that it's
expanding its capability
to launch them outside of
its borders in Belarus,
right on Ukraine and NATO's doorstep.
It's forced Ukraine to
grapple with questions
of a potential nuclear threat in the North
while trying to push forward
a major counteroffensive in the South.
Russia has been building up
this capability in Belarus
since before the full scale
invasion of Ukraine in 2022.
Much of it in the Asipovichy District,
which has become a hub for
nuclear capable weapons
transferred from Russia.
This January, 2022
satellite image from there
shows the beginning of this expansion.
Here, over a dozen Iskander components
are seen parked at a training center.
Then in February of 2023,
state media footage from the same location
shows Belarusian soldiers
training with the Russian
supplied Iskanders there.
A few miles away from this
training ground in July, 2023
we can see a garage to store
some of the Russian launchers.
The garage didn't exist in August, 2022.
Elsewhere in the Asipovichy District,
nuclear arms watchers began monitoring
another storage facility in spring of 2023
after a leaked US intelligence report
revealed Russia was considering it
to house nuclear warheads.
Nuclear weapons researchers
have spotted clues
in satellite imagery there.
Last summer, this area used
to be covered with trees.
Only the outer perimeter had fencing.
But by spring of 2023,
these additional double layers of fencing
in the inner perimeter were added.
While other features would
still need to be added,
multiple layers of fencing are a signature
of Russian nuclear warhead storage sites.
This one in Kaliningrad, Russia,
has similar layers of fencing.
The training grounds and
other facilities in Belarus
where Iskanders have been spotted,
along with the expansion
of storage arsenals
represent an important strategic expansion
of Russia's capability to
launch a nuclear weapon.
(pensive music)